Sáng ngày May 1, sau lưới đàn 2,5 mũ mê chính, bình Trung công bình, bộ quốc phòng đã tạm thời cất cầu pháu phong trư tại tình vũ thỏ từ 3 giờ 3 mũ đề bảo đam ăn toàn.
Giò mục nước xong không dân cao, trẻ sức với lưới tốc đó được trên 3 mê trình dây.
Hí lưu tốc xong trẻ xuống dưới 2 mê trình dây, lưới đàn 2,5 mũ mê chính sẽ nỗi lại cầu pháu phong trư và bảo đam rất thông qua cầu.
Nếu lưu tốc xong trẻ xuống dưới 3 mê chính dây, quân đội sẽ phục bụng người dân qua xong bằng phà quân sự.
Theo thông tin từ chúng tâm dự báo hí tự thủy văn cuốc gia, bộ nông nghiệp và mũ trường.
Một nước trên xong không qua điểm bàn tự vũ thỏ tăng gần 1 mũ mê trong bốn này, tư mũ tâm đến ngày May 1, sau, và đang đặt định ngán hạn ở mức 18 mũ mê.
Cầu phá phong trâu được bình trùng công bình lắp đặt từ ngày 3,5 mũ tâm, hành hủy chăm 2 mê tư sau sự cố sập dịch cầu phong trâu sáng ngày 1,5 mũ tâm, hành hủy chăm 2 mê tư khiến tám người gặp nạn.
Cầu pháu này giúp kích nỗi ra thông tượng tiện trong vử dân các vệ tâm nông, lắm thao và thành phố vệ trị, chẳng phải đi vòng qua cầu ngọt tháp xà hơn từ 4,5 mê đến 5 mê kí lối mê.
Cầu phong trâu mới đặc sây dựng có chiều dài gần sau trong năm May 3, tổng mức đầu tư hơn sau trong 8 mũ tì đồng,
dự kiến sẽ hoàn thiện trong phía gia tối.